And we figured out that we could take the user's 2FA code, encode it into DTMF tones and append
it to a phone number and tell Gemini call this phone number, which is one of the actions
that didn't require user prompting.
Critical, critical, critical, critical, critical.
Best part of hacking when you can just, you know, critical thing, right?
So Packers, we've got an exciting announcement.
Threat Locker Zero Trust World Conference is back in 2026.
It's going to be March 4th to March 6th in Orlando, Florida.
It's freaking gorgeous down there too during that time.
And yours truly is going to be there.
I'm going to be there on Wednesday, March 4th.
I'm going to be leading a hands-on hacking workshop.
I'll be one of many.
So there's lots of fun hacking workshops you can get involved in.
And it's going to be a great time.
There's tons of sessions, workshops, other people there to network with.
It's going to be a great conference.
So if you're local to Orlando or if you're up for the travel, this is a great way for you
to use that employer training budget that you've got.
Also for critical thinking listeners, there's a discount of $200 off.
You can use the code ZTW, right for Zero Trust World, CTBB26, ZTW, CTBB26 when you register.
That'll be on the screen and in the description as well.
It's going to be a great time.
I hope to see you guys there.
All right, let's go back to the show.
All righty, Sup Hackers, it's been a while.
It probably actually doesn't feel like a while to you guys because we pre-recorded some episodes.
But I haven't been on the pod in three weeks and I am rolling and ready to get back to it.
So, I mean, let's jump into this episode.
I'm going to be solo today.
No Rezo or Gretmi.
Rezo's got some stuff going on and Gretmi is going to be traveling for a live hacking event.
So, just your boy, Rhino Rader today.
All right, first, let's jump off into the This Week in Book Bounty segment.
You know, I have a couple of things here for this one, but actually, I'm going to turn one
of them into just a longer segment because it's really good.
So first thing that you just need to be aware of rapid fire is Integrity launched a new program
called ASWatson, this is a big like massive scope family, you know, of companies sort of situation here.
And the bounties are quite good.
We're looking at four to seven K of criticals, highs in one point two to four and a massive scope.
So watch your tier levels for sure.
I mean, obviously they go down to quite low for tier five or whatever.
But if you're hacking on the main scope, this is a nice fresh new program you can take a look at.
For a company that is very big in in Asia, the ASWatson group.
So check that out.
So that's where I'm actually done with the twib.
And now we're going to go into the actual main content for the episode.
Got a lot of news, but I'm also going to throw in some some fun tidbits for you guys.
We're going to talk a little bit about, I guess, sort of a realization that I had about sea surf,
which I feel like I should have known, but didn't really hit.
And then at the end, we're going to talk a little bit about cross consumer attacks, which is something that Franz
Franz and I have been working a little bit on in the critical thinkers research guild from a while back.
So we're going to cover that as well.
OK, so first up, though, before we jump into those things is the yes, we hack 2026 report.
So I try to go through each one of these like bug bounty program or platform reports whenever they come out and grab these full tidbits for you guys.
And not going to lie, yes, we hack is putting out some pretty sick content for all this.
So actually, let me go ahead and expand my screen here.
I'm going to give you guys a lot of the data out of this report, but I would also recommend you go check it out.
We're going to we're going to link it in the description.
First, they're showing they're giving more data on how hunters are actively using AI.
This is an N of 245.
So this is 245 hackers surveyed for this.
And most hackers are using AI for improved report clarity and structure, which I don't know if it's getting them more clarity or not, because I've seen some really crap AI generated reports lately.
I still don't use AI to generate my reports.
I help it.
I have it help sometimes when I'm doing something particularly complex, but I write all of my reports by hand, typically.
And that I find that that gets them accepted more and more quickly.
32% are using it to create think creatively and thanks to the automation and 31% are using it to find more bugs, more complex and subtle bugs.
I've had a lot of success in the past couple of weeks with using Opus 4.6 to find some very, very deep client side bugs that I wouldn't have found.
So I definitely recommend you guys use something like JxScout to get the JavaScript files down and then throw it into cloud code and just have it go ham, because it does a very good job of analyzing client side routes, query parameter parsing, hash parsing, post message listeners, all sorts of things.
So definitely recommend you take a look at that and we see 69% are using AI for learning and documentation, 51% for drafting reports, 40% for payload generation, 38% for code review and vulnerability analysis.
Payload generation I think is a big one for me. 26% for recon and 23% for escalating bones. 9% are not using AI. So, I mean, we're seeing a lot of rapid adoption here. I would definitely recommend you join this 40% that's using it for payload generation and 38% for code review and vulnerability analysis. It is extremely, extremely good. And that's coming from like a pretty experienced client side hacker. It is amazing.
So definitely build out your own workflow for that. All right. Next one was on page 44 that I thought was interesting. Of the hunters surveyed, 44% have been hacking for three to five years, which is not as long as expected, to be honest. So that's pretty encouraging. And 38% of hunters are full-time hunters on YesWeHack, which is kind of crazy. 62% are doing it in addition to some other role.
So, it's good to see the full-time hunters growing a little bit. I like that. And I was surprised to see that number be so high. We're also seeing the best ways to improve your hacking skills are as YouTube videos. You know, hey, maybe you're watching this on YouTube. YesWeHackDojo and...
Oh, okay. So actually, it's like hands-on practice with bug bounty platforms first. And then we're also seeing YouTube videos, YesWeHackDojo, online educational platforms, and blog posts and write-ups, which I totally agree with.
We've also seen a 520% increase in collaboration reports on YesWeHack, which is sick. So lots of collaboration going on. And the top tools in the toolkit are BurpSuite, Fuff, and HTTPX, which makes sense. Unfortunately, we're only seeing Kaido down here at 18% adoption versus 91% on BurpSuite.
So, it seems like in the YesWeHack world, Kaido is only at 18%, but a lot of the top hunters I know are using Kaido. So, surprising.
But, yeah, I guess, you know, old habits die hard.
Yeah. Also, I wanted to call out this on page 55. There are top performing hunters by CWB types.
And I know, okay, guys, we're getting into a little bit of meta here, okay?
But, like, there are some recon boys out there that will not talk about what they do at all.
And this guy, this little graph here gives us a little bit, a peek into what exactly they might be doing.
GoDiego has, you know, denied my request to come on the pod multiple times.
And he is coming in as the top hacker for cash poisoning. So that could be a part of his secret methodology.
And doxing, of course, unsurprisingly, is coming in with subdomain takeovers.
So, cash poisoning and subdomain takeovers are probably what are making these guys top of the leaderboard right now, which is really cool to see.
They also included a long section on various hackers' expertise.
So, you know, Chakall's methodology for stored XSS.
There's one for information disclosure, IDOR, etc.
So if you're looking to know, like, what the methodology is for these top hackers, this is a good place to find it.
Overall, I thought this report was really awesome.
They talked about the live hacking events.
They talked about the assessment of, you know, vulnerabilities that people are finding.
They're sharing methodology.
And they even also highlight some of the research.
Let's see if I can find it.
Yeah.
Some of my favorite research that came out this year, Exploiting Syntax Confusions in the Wild by Alex Brumann.
So definitely worth a read.
High quality bug bounty platform report.
Okay.
So we went through that.
Let's jump now over to what I was going to talk about with regards to C-Surf.
Okay.
So I was exploiting a bug the other day.
And I was like, okay, you know, I've got this C-Surf.
It does something to the victim's account that would be more helpful if I could do it multiple times.
And I was like, ah, man, I'm going to have to, like, pop up a new tab and, like, distract the user while I'm, like, redirecting and stuff like that.
And then I realized, you know, hey, even though this has X-frame options set to deny, it doesn't matter.
And the same-site cookies are none for this, which was what we wanted.
So it's still sending, you know, the cookies into the iframe.
It's just not going to be able to show the result.
But it doesn't matter for C-Surf because it's a state-changing thing.
So, you know, what I ended up doing was just creating a bunch of iframes with this state-changing, you know, action.
And all of them, you know, failed to load because X-frame options was denied, but it doesn't matter because the cookies are sent and the request is processed server-side.
So I was just able to, like, brrrr, like, send a bunch of, you know, C-Surf at the same time.
And I don't know why I hadn't really wrapped my head around it, but, like, X-frame options doesn't get processed, obviously, until the response is processed.
And by that point, the C-Surf has already had its effect.
So just, like, make sure, I know it gets tricky nowadays with, like, iframes and, like, fetch requests and stuff like that and what cookies are going to be sent with the same site and that sort of thing.
But really, for C-Surf, you know, the thing you need to be checking is, does it have the same site cookies in place, right?
You don't really have to think about, oh, is it iframeable or not iframeable?
In this situation, I had to do it by an iframe versus fetch.
But just keep that in mind, that, you know, X-frame options is not, doesn't prevent you from executing C-surf inside of an iframe.
Just a thought there.
All right, up next is a write-up by our own Monke.
And this is a collab between Monke, Rezo, me, and Lupin at a live hacking event in Tokyo.
And this was one, a very fun, creative bug that we all did together.
And it was released on StarStrike.ai's blog, which is Bus Factor and Monke's new AI consulting firm.
So this is such a fun bug.
I wanted to tell you guys about it.
He does a great introduction into, like, the anatomy of a data exfiltration vulnerability in modern AI environments.
But the TLDR of the situation is, you know, we've got some way to deliver the payload.
You get the actual data that you need, and then you exfil that, right?
So there's kind of those three components that you need.
So the delivery component for this exploit was a intent URI that you can utilize inside of the Gemini app, which would allow you to preload a query into the victim's Gemini.
And because it loads so quickly, you can actually use tap jacking for this.
So, you know, you create an app, they're tapping, you know, hey, tap this button five times.
They tap it one, two, three, right?
And then on the third, you trigger the intent swap and preload the prompt in.
And then by the time they're done tapping, you know, their finger is right on the send button for Gemini, and it triggers the exploit.
So it's kind of like click jacking.
It's not the most optimal method, and we actually figured out a way to, you know, deliver this payload differently afterwards.
But tap jacking is an interesting term that we don't talk about a ton.
So I just wanted to highlight that for y'all, is that that is a way to get your payload in, in a worst-case scenario.
So anyway, we got the payload in.
We said, hey, Gemini, you know, because it has access to the user's data, their messages and stuff like that on the Android device,
we could say, hey, grab the 2FA code from the user's message, and now we got to get it out, right?
So that's the exfiltration piece.
And we actually did this via DTMF tones, which is some OG hacker shit right here, which that's those tones you hear when you call the number and it goes ding, ding, ding, you know, and it's like, you know, putting in these specific numbers via frequencies, right?
So what we found is that if you put the, you know, I believe it was a hashtag or maybe it was a semicolon, it's a semicolon after the number, you know, you can get it to automatically play these DTMF tones.
And we figured out that we could take the user's 2FA code, encode it into DTMF tones and append it to a phone number until Gemini called this phone number, which is one of the actions that didn't require user prompting, right?
So with that one tap on the tap jack, it would read the messages, grab the 2FA code, and then call us.
And we had like the sick POC video where we had like another phone sitting right next to it.
And, you know, we'd pick up the phone and it would go do, do, do, do, do, do, do, or whatever, you know, the DTMF tone.
And then you would see the 2FA code pop up on the attacker's phone because it was, it was, you know, processing the DTMF tones.
So that is a good way to let me say that is a way to exfiltrate data in these sort of environments.
And I was really proud of the team for coming up with that really creative solution.
And yeah, Google liked it.
So we, we got a bounty and we got, um, one through three, seven bonus, uh, for the most creative vulnerability of that live hacking event.
So that was a blast.
Um, all right.
Up next is some, some news that we kind of have to cover.
That's a little bit, a little bit tricky, um, which is hacker one recently, and I'll give a shout out to, uh, W2W here who tweeted this out.
Um, both Spotify and the hacker one program, um, decreased their bounties pretty substantially lately.
This is not something we like to see, especially from a platform.
Um, and I've reached out to hacker one to get a comment on this.
Uh, unfortunately this happened just super recently and we're kind of recording this episode last minute anyway.
So I haven't had the opportunity to get hacker one to give us a comment on that, but we're going to cover that comment on the next episode.
Um, because I think they will get back to us, uh, about it, but, um, you know, here I am, I'm wearing a hacker one shirt.
If you can't see, I'm wearing a hacker one, uh, t-shirt.
Um, this is not great to see, but you know, hacker one is still paying good bounties here.
You know, they're paying 1500 for a medium, 7k for a high 15k for a crit.
Um, I, I am confused by their, their decision to decrease their bounties.
So, uh, uh, I, uh, I guess we'll see how they respond to that next time.
Um, but I think the general sentiment is that they are, um, doing that in alignment with other bug money programs.
And to which the hacker response is, well, you need to be setting the, the tone, but not following.
Right.
Um, so we'll see what hacker one's response to that is also in, in the PR, in the PR hits that H1 has been taking right now.
Um, there's also some people that have been highlighting section 3.1 of hacker one's general terms and conditions, which says, and I quote hacker one may use confidential information to develop and or improve its services.
For example, identify trends and train AI models provided such use does not result in disclosure of confidential information to unauthorized third parties.
Now, a lot of people are interpreting this to mean, you know, Hey, they're taking our data.
They're training like, you know, the super hacker AI.
Um, I, I have spoken with some hacker one representatives in the past that have claimed that that is not the case.
Um, and there's no project under underway for that.
Um, but there is something in the terms and conditions here.
Um, my intuition is that, that this is being used, you know, in context with high, which is hacker one's AI system, which helps write reports and deal with that sort of thing.
Um, and this is sort of like a catch all statement.
Um, but a lot of hackers are sort of dismayed by that.
And, and don't want their confidential information being used, um, with AI models.
So I also reached out to hacker one to get a comment on that and we'll see what they say.
Um, but these, uh, terms and conditions have been in effect since, uh, July 20th of 24.
So it's been a while at this point, uh, and I'm not sure why it's just coming back up into the public eye, but I did want to address it for you all, um, in full transparency.
And I will let you know when we hear back more from hacker one about that.
All right.
Uh, up next is, uh, I just wanted to give a shout a little bit here.
Um, when you're done with today's episode of critical thinking, this is going to be a short episode.
Uh, we, I got a lot going on right now, but, um, when you're done with this episode,
I recommend you go over to turbo seven, uh, URB zero YouTube channel and watch research review.
Number negative two RCE and Google's AI code editor, anti-gravity by Sudi.
So this is one of the best hackers I know who is unfortunately also like from my little town that I live in.
So I can't even claim to be the best hacker in my little town, you know, is, uh, is this guy turbo and he's amazing.
Um, and he's doing a review of some research and giving his comments.
And this guy is just so full of passion for hacking.
Like you guys know me, I'm full of passion for hacking.
He is full of passion for hacking.
Okay.
Um, and he's going to be releasing some videos.
It seems, uh, doing research reviews, uh, and just kind of giving his thoughts.
And he actually does some research reviews for us at critical thinking as well.
Um, applications into the research lab.
So, um, he does a great job with this and he he's very, very smart.
So if you want to go hear his, um, research reviews, you can find that on his YouTube channel.
We'll link that in the description.
So if you're looking for a little bit of extra content to fill in where a CTBB is, is lacking
this week, then, uh, turbo's got you covered.
All right.
Um, last but not least, I did want to talk to you guys a little bit about some, um, research
that I think we mentioned on the pod a while back that Franz and I were kind of cooking on,
um, a while back.
Um, so let me take a drink of my water real quick.
Okay.
Let's get to that.
So this is something that we are sort of branding cross consumer attacks, and I'm hoping
that we'll get a write up on the, um, on the critical thinking research lab soon on these
types of attacks.
We've pocked them in several areas and we've also seen them, you know, out in the community
pretty often.
Um, and what these are, are essentially scenarios where a target company is utilizing a third party
to do something like, um, load JavaScript files, documentation, you know, whatever it is, right?
Um, support apps or whatever.
And they've got part of their domain pointed at this third party and they've got, um, uh, or maybe
like a path even on their main domain pointed at this third party.
Right.
Um, and what you can do is you can sign up for that third party yourself and create your own
tenant or whatever, and then host content on your tenant.
Right.
Let's call it like an SVG file or an HTML file or whatever.
And then, um, take that URL that is used to access your own content and try to access
it on the target.
Right.
So the scenario that we're, we're talking about here is, you know, you've got some website
and maybe like, it's like slash docs slash one, three, five, six, eight, one, four slash,
you know, test.html or whatever.
And, you know, that ID just looks like an ID or right.
And, um, and so, you know, if you can access your uploaded content to this third party on your
target's domain, then you may be able to induce things like XSS.
Um, we've seen this many times.
It's very hard to fix because for the third party, like, uh, you know, these URLs are supposed
to be public, but only under your domain.
Right.
So it's kind of tricky.
You know, you get into those situations where it's like, okay, well, they're accessing,
you know, public content or whatever.
Um, so it's, it's tricky.
You know, a lot of, a lot of third party providers are, are pretty vulnerable to this.
Um, so just keep that in mind as an attack vector.
I know that hacking third parties is a little bit, you know, weird sometimes or whatever.
Um, but we've seen this accepted quite often and, you know, impact is king nowadays.
So just make sure you're proving impact.
So let me give you a couple of tips for that.
Uh, obviously check out URLs in the path.
Sometimes there's also slugs in the path, you know, instead of, you know, slash Google,
you put in slash Reinerator and now it's got, you know, Reinerators, you know, uploaded content
to their, um, look for file uploads, right?
So you were looking for SVG files.
We're looking for HTML files, even hosting JS files can, there can help you, you know, bypass,
um, CSP or something like that.
Um, so keep that in mind.
Um, you can also, you know, sometimes they have these hosts as like holes in their CSP
in general, um, which can help for, you know, data exfiltration or, um, XSS, of course.
And then, um, one other area that I've seen this work or two other areas is sometimes these
like paths that you have, um, sort of dedicated from the main domain, the main victim domain
to this third party, they will accept parameters that will allow you to override what host the
content is related to.
So just kind of run gal, you know, do some Google dorking on that sort of
path pattern and see if there's any parameters that pop up and read the documentation
for the third party a lot, um, to understand if there's any debug parameters that will allow
you to say, Hey, I know that this is on, you know, Google's domain or whatever, but instead,
uh, you know, let's, let's go ahead and point it to Rhino Raiders.
And then that will allow you to override.
So that's an interesting technique.
Um, and then last but not least, sometimes there are specific tokens for this.
So rather than just an ID in the URL or whatever, they like sign a URL or they'll
like generate a JWT token or something like that, which will allow you to access that
restricted content.
Um, check for the scenarios where the third party is downloading files, not like PDF
files and stuff like that, not just like generating HTML pages or whatever.
Um, and sometimes those signed URLs or those, um, uh, specific, um, patterns of accessing it
via a token will allow you to, uh, access your data on a different customer site, which can
induce XSS.
So, uh, keep a lookout for those sort of attacks.
We're calling those cross consumer attacks.
I think it fits the concept pretty well.
And, um, we've seen them quite often around, so, uh, keep, keep your eye out and yeah, drop
something in the CTPB discord.
If you guys find one, uh, I would like to know how, how, uh, you know, common they are
around and hear about any success stories you guys might have with that.
All right.
Um, that's about it.
That's all I've got for you guys today.
Go watch that content by turbo and, uh, I'll see you guys next week.
Peace.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for watching to the end.
Y'all, if you want more critical thinking content, uh, or if you want to support the show, head
over to CTPB dot show slash discord, you can hop in the community.
There's lots of great high level hacking discussion happening there on top of the masterclasses,
hack longs, exclusive content, and a full-time hunters guild.
If you're a full-time hunter, it's a great time.
Trust me.
I'll see you there.
you